- Way bigger businesses than you
have been put out of business
because of technology shifts.
When I invested in
Uber five years ago,
I called my dad's
Russian friends in L.A.
They came to this
country in '78, '79.
They were dead broke.
They lived in studio apartments.
They drove taxi cabs for
two, three bucks an hour.
Hustled their way, worked every
hour, no Saturday and Sunday
for 20 years, built up a
business, didn't buy anything,
saved all their money,
eventually bought their own car,
eventually had four or five
guys or girls underneath them,
built a business,
had the American dream,
finally got into
their 50s and 60s,
worked every goddamn
minute to get there,
and now were gonna kind of,
like, enjoy it a little bit.
And then Uber came along.
And so I called
Marik and Vladimir
and these guys and said, "Hey."
Vladimir, I know.
And said, "Vlad, I've got
good news and bad news.
"Good news is you've
done well and
"America's the greatest
country in the world.
"Bad news is you
might be in trouble."
And literally, the
three of them, verbatim,
were all like, "That's nice,
boy chick, we'll be okay.
"So, what you're telling me
is they're gonna take a phone
"and hit a button and
the car is gonna come?
"Very good, very good,
I'll talk to you later."
That's a funny story
and I say it funny.
Here's what's not funny:
every one of those
three guys' businesses
have been slaughtered.
Absolutely slaughtered.
All of their businesses now,
that they're trying to sell,
are literally worth
15 cents on the dollar
of what it was worth
just four years ago.
(light music)